hi my name is aushi Verma and I'm a data
science fellow at The Institute for
defense analyses or Ida as we call it
for
sure so this presentation is a story of
how we answer the question of how to
connect our researchers with each other
each of who have different skill sets in
order to Foster more interdisplinary
collaboration and we did this using our
company's data strategy along with data
govern data management and governance
principles and something called the
research taxonomies in order to produce
our solution called itry which I'll be
explaining throughout this
presentation and this process helped us
answer the question to deliver key
insights to our researchers all powered
by
R so first and foremost what exact ly is
idem we are a nonprofit ffrdc or a
federally funded research and
development center which means that it
is our job to perform unbiased
scientifically rigorous analyses to
answer us National Security and science
policy questions for our government
sponsors and
business we have eight research
divisions as part of our systems and
analyses center and we have our Science
and Technology policy Institute which we
sort of consider a ninth research
division our core values are rigorous
analysis trusted expertise inclusion
collaboration Innovation and service to
the
nation our research staff perform a lot
of research across many broad domains
and
areas so the core component of our
objective and rigorous analyses is data
we deal with and depend on a lot of data
for our
research and this is why Ida is in a
data strategy to establish a data
Centric culture and to leverage data to
efficiently respond to research
questions so this strategy develops
solid and sustainable infrastructures
and practices to promote a data first
approach to our work through multiple
initiatives one of the key initiatives
of the data strategy has been the
development of a set of research
taxonomies as an institution Ida has a
defined set of core competencies which
are rooted in our values which I talked
about on the previous slide so the data
strategy Drew on these core competencies
and looking at the types of work Fields
tools technologies that they are related
to in order to create our research
taxonomies and these taxonomies are a
organized hierarchy of keywords that
describe the research done at Ida across
these eight broad
domains so our research divisions work
on lots of projects and the projects
have deliverable products like reports
or
memorandums and so we can use the
metadata for these projects and products
and combine them with the research
tonomy terms to quantify and describe
our
research and this works through another
initiative which is a periodic tagging
effort where the authors of the products
tag them with relevant terms from the
tonomy such that it describes that
particular body of
work and this creates a data set of
products authors and tonomy
terms we combine this with other data
sources like project author and division
data to produce a data set that
describes the research we do here at
Ida This research data set brings
together a cohesive and quantitative
picture of the research done here which
is bringing new insights to our research
staff in
management so we created an interactive
shiny application that visually shows
the
data this is the shiny application and
we call it it Tre which is short for Ida
taxonomical research expertise
Explorer I'll walk you through the app
soon but first I'll describe how exactly
are enabled us to do this so this is how
the magic happens this is a pipeline
showing our process and I will walk you
through each step of of the process so
prior to it tree our data had been
pretty disperate we had some data being
stored in sqlite uh database files we
had some data on our SQL Server we had
some static data being stored in uh
comma separate value or CSV files and we
had some RDS
objects so using the magic of R and our
studio we ingested these data uh from
the different data sources and with the
packages uh listed here uh we cleaned
these data and we combined them together
in order to produce a single coherent
data set we outputed this as a RDS
object and we passed this to our shiny
application which takes in this RDS uh
data set and displays a table and a
graph uh which I'll be walking you
through very soon so this entire
pipeline is being hosted or the shiny
application is being hosted on our
company's internal shiny servers and in
order to deploy this pipeline we hosted
on a Docker container and we have
periodic cron jobs which are refreshing
the data uh in the pipeline
occasionally so with the data Pipeline
and Chinese help we are now able to
answer five very specific questions
about a research I would like to take a
moment to point out this great quote I
saw in Google which says that from a
drop of data an ocean of wisdom can
emerge which I think is a great analogy
to where data set because it's a
relatively simple and minimalistic data
set but by combining the previously
disparate sources of data we are now
able to extract impactful insights that
help our researchers and
staff okay finally on to the application
so this is our our shiny app it tree and
it has five tabs at the top Each of
which is answering a very specific
question so this is the first tab which
answers the question of who are the top
researchers for a given research
area on the left panel here is the
research taxonomy and other data
filtering options and on the right is a
graph and a table showing the results
which is percentage of the author's
products that were tagged with selected
term from the
taxonomy it is shinese reactivity and
modularity which are helping us to
provide this very simple no fuss
interface for our users to interact with
this data
set
uh because on the second tab on the
first tab uh the screenshot could not
fit all the filtering options on the
left here are the rest of the filtering
options so aside from selecting the
research area which is a term from the
tonomy the user is able to select a
range of taxonomy terms so by selecting
narrower terms they are able to select
products that have been tagged with
their selected term as well as all of
the terms that fall below it in the
hierarchy
if they choose only the selected term
then the program will count only
products that have been taged with that
term they can filter the data set by
year the uh product was published in
they can filter by the research division
that that product was published in they
can include formal products informal
products or both types of products they
can include uh authors who are active
who are still active at Ida authors who
are inactive or all
authors they can also select the minimum
number of total products for authors
which means that they can set the
minimum number of total products that an
author has published and this may be
useful in order to get a more
comprehensive understanding of the
percentage being displayed so as an
example if an author has published say
24 products and 22 of them uh are tagged
with uh the user selected term then that
gives an indication that this author is
most likely very proficient in that
research
area finally there are some display
options as well uh the user can Rank by
uh most number of products um or least
number of products and they can also
select the total number of authors to
display and finally they can download
the graph as a as a JPEG or the table as
a CSV file for further analysis if they
so
wish so this is the second tab which
answers the question of what is the
research expertise or research profile
of an author the user can select an
author say Jane do and now they can see
Jane Do's most uh frequently uh tagged
terms in their products so uh this is
looking specifically at the percentage
of the author's products that have been
tagged with some some terms so as an
example here we can see that Jane Doe
has a lot of proficiency in statistical
analysis techniques uh operational test
and evaluation and some other
topics the third tab answers the
question of what research does a
division produce so this time instead of
looking at the research profile of an
author we're looking at the research
profile of a division so this time we
select a division and we can see the uh
the most frequently used used terms that
appear in in products uh for that
division so specifically here we are
looking at the percentage of a
division's products which have been
tagged with
terms this is the fourth tab which
answers the question of who are the top
researchers for a division this time
again we can select a division and we
can see who which authors have published
the most or least a number of products
within that division
so specifically here we are looking at
the percentage of the division's
products with that
author finally the fifth tab answers the
question of how do the divisions produce
research for an
area uh and here specifically again what
we're looking at is what percentage of
the division's products were tagged with
selected terms so here again we can
select a research area from the taxonomy
and we can see uh which divisions have
produced how many uh and number of
products in under that research
area this is a bonus uh sixth tab which
is looking at a free form sandbox
exploration of the taxonomies so if the
user wishes to see or explore the
hierarchies of of the taxonomies they
can head over to this tab and just have
a look and learn about the relationships
between the
tags
so this application it Tre was launched
earlier this year in January and
researchers are already using it for
many different things like finding
subject matter experts cross divisions
or like a networking tool or to quantify
the research uh done and many more so
this current iteration of it Tre is a
stepping stone for bringing more
insights to research staff we still have
a lot more work to do in it Tre and some
of these next steps include integrating
more data streams so that we have a more
holistic view of the data maybe trying
to automate and streamline these taging
efforts and it would be really cool to
visualize these networks and perhaps
even recommend researchers who have
similar expertise to each other or
divisions which have similar expertise
as each
other so to conclude this is how we
built a data science solution to help
our researchers we used our company's
data strategy we used data management
and governance principles we used our
company's research
taxonomies and we were able to produce a
shiny app called it tree using the magic
of R and our
shiny thank you very much for
watching